[Music]
kyle
is with us in charlotte north carolina
hey kyle how are you
hey i'm good how are y'all better than
we deserve sir how can we help
all right so i have a couple questions i
have a
house that my parents built and then
when they split up my brother stayed in
the house the house has been put into my
name
mama says just for tax purposes so i
want to sell the house while the market
is good which you don't really want me
to
so i don't want to do that but i'm also
want to start a business flipping houses
now it's probably not the best time to
do that
but i do have a line of credit against
my house because the house is paid off
so starting up businesses flipping
houses is very expensive so
a couple of questions should i move out
of the house and start my own i'm 30
years old
start my own life without that and is it
okay to use the helios against the house
to start flipping
houses since they're doing such an
expensive business to get started in
okay there's a lot going on here um
the first thing is it sounds like
morally it's not your house
did she give it to you or did she just
deed it to you for her
she did it to me for her indeed for now
she says it eventually
i don't you've got all the liability and
all the problems
and none of the benefits right just put
it just
quit claiming to eat it right back to
her and let her have her own house and
then you go about your business and go
about your life um
which means you don't have any money
right right
and you don't have any way to borrow a
home equity loan
on a house you don't own right correct
yeah which you don't need to be
leveraging that house
especially if it's you don't need to be
leveraging it period but you especially
don't want to do it if it's really not
yours
morally because morally it's her house
that's what we're saying right
okay so we clean that part up now let's
go back to the other part about flipping
houses
this is what i did i used to buy
foreclosure real estate
in my 20s and i would
borrow the money to do it and i would
flip the house
and make a profit and i would borrow the
money
to buy rental properties as well and ho
in some cases hold them sometimes it
took a lot longer to flip than i thought
um and i've done
in excess of 2000 real estate deals in
my life
so i've actually done for a living
what you're talking about doing so this
is not some
theory i actually did it right and
um uh
so and i went broke doing it uh
because i had borrowed three million
dollars after it was all said and done
and i had about four million dollars
worth of real estate and the bank
uh got sold to another bank and they
called our notes and we spent the next
two and a half years of our life
selling everything to to try to beat
foreclosures
we became a foreclosure after we used to
buy foreclosures
and we lost everything by the time i was
28 i had to start over that's the dave
ramsey story
so all of that to say uh you can
make money flipping houses in the in a
market as hot as this it's very
difficult
because the trick is buying it at a deal
in order to sell it at retail you buy it
below wholesale and you sell it at
retail
like you do anything in business right
and um
and so that's very very difficult in a
white hot market where anything that
comes on the market no matter how bad
how ugly or how messed up it is is
bringing premium price
in two days and so it's just really
really hard to find a good deal on a
property
in a market like this so that's that's
uh
thing number one thing number two is
it's the the only way i would suggest
you do this
is with cash which means you've got some
savings to do
saving to do with your career before you
move on
to buying your first property with cash
and if you flip with cash
and in a market that's not white hot it
can be done it's
very difficult it's a lot more difficult
than they tell you at the
real estate seminar where they where
they charge you three thousand dollars
to learn how to do it
yeah kyle i want to know are you
planning to do a lot of the work
yourself are you you consider yourself a
carpenter a handyman fix-it-upper guy
yeah i am
okay i'm sorry i have a hard time
understanding are you currently employed
in the construction industry
uh not in the residential industry next
okay
well i gotta tell you uh if it's me i'm
gonna start a renovation
uh handyman business because you need to
come up with the extra cash yes
right so i'd start doing that let me
tell you why uh
not only is it very practical for you to
make extra money to be able to save up
to buy your first house and cash flow
something really small
you're going to get the experience that
you need to do it for yourself and
somebody else is paying you to do it
and let me tell you something in
charlotte north carolina i would say
dave
that's very similar to nashville as far
as market size
economy uh you start doing bathrooms
uh additions over garages someone else
is paying you
you can make some really really good
money and again get great experience
learn who the subs are because all of
those subs
those relationships and those
experiences and that money all has to
come together
i'd start a small business grow it slow
cash just cash cash cash and just
put it away put it away put it away and
before you know it you know two three
years from now you're doing something
you really love
you might be doing it full time now and
then you put away the money
to buy that first house and flip i think
that's the best path forward dave
because he enjoys it number one
number two he gets the experience he
needs someone else is paying for it i
love it
so kyle the rule is this and and i broke
the rule and you will break the rule
when you use borrowed money to buy a
property
you're not as careful and you pay more
if you're putting money that you've
saved over three years i've been saving
like crazy
and i've got to go buy this house and i
start thinking about i wonder what that
roof is going to cost
i got to put a roof on it you're going
to know what that roof is going to cost
before you buy the property
and you're going to know what the value
of that property is after rehab you're
not going to guess
yeah and you're not going to get in a
hurry and you're not going to get sucked
into a bad deal
when you're spending real money not
borrowed money
borrowed money makes people sloppy
they don't pay attention and they do
worse deals and that's how people go
broke